um another one I'm going to talk about
offering reinforcement
um this talk I'm going to focus on using
function approximation for reinforcement
learning
um but since this is the you know the
last talk of this Workshop so unlike
what Java did in the morning I'm not
going to tell you any negative results
mostly I'm only going to tell you about
positive results so that when the
workshop is over when we get back home
we still feel you know optimistic about
working on reinforced money
all right um so this is a joint work
with two Cornell students the students
massage and Jonathan
foreign
so in the past decade we have seen many
successful stories exciting stories
about reinforcement learning practice
you know we use Ro techniques to solve
these extremely challenging games such
as Foe and video games and recently we
can even use RL to train policies to
manipulate a very complicated object and
actually train a policy better than
traditional methods like Optimal control
emotion planning could do on This Global
manipulation I think one of the lessons
we can learn from these successful
stories is that when we combine
reinforcement learning together with
which function approximation and under
the situation where we have a lot of
training data for instance in the
simulations we can often find a very
good policy you know policies that
better that we can hand engineer
so this is the typical pipeline for
online reinforcement learning so as you
can see here there's a closed loop we
have an aria component where it computes
policies to interact with the real world
in this case it's a low ball arm trying
to manipulate the ball
and then um when the policy interacts
with the environment it generates data
and then the reinforcement learning
agent will access this data set and try
to refine the policy and then this
process goes on for many many many
Innovations until we are satisfied about
the performance of the policy
so online reinforcement is a very
popular setting you know um it's it's
um very challenging setting as well I
personally also spend a lot of time
thinking about online reinforcement only
but I think there are several um
sort of um
I guess issues about this setting
um I think first of all
um
the learning could be very slow at the
beginning especially you know at the
very beginning we don't have enough data
and we sort of have to do very smart
exploration to collect very useful and
diverse data
and then we automatically have to do
some exploration we have to do some sort
of random exploration in this process
but sometimes it's questionable you know
whether random exploration is actually
safe or not right for those safety
critical applications like autonomous
driving for instance
so um different from online
reinforcement learning so the offline
reinforcement learning Paradigm works
like this as you can see here there's no
closed loop anymore
we only have a static data set which is
collected by some Behavior policy by
such subscript B
so this policy could be in this case for
instance some policy where you know
students used to control this robot to
the different kind of tasks maybe
similar tasks but not exactly the same
right so we have a lot of local data
about this robot interacting with
different kind of objects for instance
and in this offline reinforcement
learning Paradigm we only want to use
this static data set to directly learn a
policy Pi that can work well on the task
that we care about today and once we
learn that policy we want to directly
deploy that policy in the real world
right so we don't want to do any
exploration in this case we don't want
to do any online interaction
so the benefit of this framework could
be that we will be able to leverage a
huge offline data set
and then we don't have to do any online
exploration so this might be more
suitable for applications where you know
safety is important
what are the potential applications for
firmware enforcement so I think the
first application is robotics
um so this is the work from I think
Google where they build a lowball Farm
where they just deploy these robots and
let them do sort of random interactions
with the objects in the Spain they let
the robot do this interaction in a 24
times 7 fashion they collected a huge
offline data and then at the end they
try to train a policy using this large
offline data to sort of learn how to
pick and replace objects from this pane
and another application is autonomous
driving where um
we human drivers could contribute a lot
of data
um but in this kind of cases if you want
to do random exploration in real world
it might be a little bit dangerous right
and then I think the third application
which I personally really like it is
this blue navigation example so in this
recent nature paper where they use
offline reinforcement methods to learn a
policy to navigate this world so the
goal here is to learn a control policy
for this room so that it can stay in the
predefined position and also sort of
by leveraging sort of the wind field to
minimize the total energy cost
and the offline data here is the
pre-logged data from some sort of
handcraft crafted feature before
and of course there are a lot of other
applications in healthcare I'm not the
expert in this area but there is a very
nice offline reinforcement survey paper
from Berkeley where they talk a lot
about this potential Healthcare
applications
all right so
um
hopefully I convince you that offering
reinforcement is interesting but offline
reinforcement is also challenging and in
order to see that let's contrast it
against the traditional supervised
learning for instance
so introduce in traditional supervised
learning setting we have
a huge offline sort of static data set
as well so in this case just data sets
about image and their labels and we
train a model we train a nonlinear
function proximator as a classifier and
once we have that we can Define them we
can deploy this function in real world
and test it on examples that we probably
haven't seen in the training time
right so
um in traditional supervised learning
setting we often assume that the
training distribution is equal to the
test the test distribution
but this is not really going to be true
in offline reinforcement learning
setting where we're going to face some
distribution shift
so let's consider this example of
learning to drive from expert
demonstrations so I have a huge offline
data set that consists of expert
demonstrations about driving you know
the car right and I won't learn a policy
that maps from state to actions in this
case maybe the steering angle and then
once I learned the policy I want to
deploy that right but when I deploy that
I will actually use my own policy to
drive the car right I will actually make
predictions on the states that will be
generated by my policy rather than the
expert policy in that case right so it
might look like that you know because
the learning process is not perfect
you're going to make some mistakes along
the way and then mistakes compound and
eventually you get to region where you
don't have any training data in this
case
okay so this is different from the
traditional supervised learning study
okay so in this talk we're going to
focus on some answering this question
how should we tackle off language
learning um you know what are the
settings what are the goals and uh
specifically for for the setting where
the offline data does not have
sufficient coverage
so in terms of outline first I will talk
about what are the goals that we
potentially want to achieve in offline
reinforcement and then we will talk
about an algorithm that sort of achieved
this code and in the last part of this
talk I will switch to a slightly
different setting setting called
imitation learning or inverse reinforced
learning where you don't have reward
signals anymore but you may have some
high quality demonstrations together
with a large offline data data set
okay so the model we're going to stick
to is the finite Horizon Markov decision
process I think you have seen this
setting multiple times but let me just
spend you know 20 seconds on that so
that we can be on the same page in terms
of notations right so we will have
to try to denote policy the policy maps
from state to actions and once the
environment received an action it will
output the rewarded signal and it also
outputs the next state which is sampled
from the unknown markovian transition
p-stop
uh in finite Horizon setting this
process repeats for Capital H many steps
and your goal is to find a policy Pi
that maximize the expected total reward
across Capital H many steps
that is our goal
and for offline reinforcement
before we start doing learning there is
this process of collecting offline data
so in this case we assume that we have
some Behavior policy Pi subscript B
which
has already interacted with the
environment for many many runs
and I'm going to use this notation D
superscript pi to denote the state
action distribution induced by policy pi
right you can think about this as the
average you know State action
distribution induced by the policy pi
over this Capital many capital x many
steps
we go into Zoom that we have an offline
data set that is in the format of State
action next state triples where the
state action pairs are sampled from this
state action distribution induced by the
behavior policy and the next state as
Prime is sampled from the unknown
covalent transition condition on the
state action pair essay
and for Simplicity let's assume this
data triples they are ID samples
that is my offline data
I forget one thing in the data set we
should also have
um
oh actually so throughout this talk I'm
going to assume that the reorder
function is known so I'm not going to
spend time and effort on learning the
water function
we don't yeah so particularly we don't
know for instance what is the likely
what is the probability of taking this
action a under the given State as we
don't have these numbers
but if you have a sample that you have
an example of trajectories maybe for
maintaining ID assumptions they just for
each trajectory and just take a trip or
randomly simple a triple and throw it
with the rest and take the next items
to take some intervals in this ideas
so that's it the question on follow-up
on that like do we know if you know the
policy then would it help s us
um I think if you know the probability
of getting this action a under this s we
might be able to use some of the
importance of these techniques but um
you might get into this exponential so
first of all horizontation right
okay so
um as I said we will focus on the
setting where the alternate distribution
does not have sufficient coverage so let
me think simplify this problem so in
this x-axis
um uh let's let's let's use this x axis
to represent the state action space so I
have a distribution that looks like that
this is the distribution over State
action pairs induced by my offline
distribution offline policy
so
um in the worst case you know my optimal
my globally optimal policy by stars
distribution might be somewhere here
which does not overlap with the offline
distribution at all
so in this case
there seems very little hope that we can
aim to find you know this Global optimal
policy Pi Star right after all we don't
have any data on the part of the state
space where the optimal policy is going
to visit so we really don't know
what's going to happen in those regions
but maybe we can focus on search on over
high quality policies that are
potentially covered by the offline
distribution so for in this case I may
have Pi 1.2 by 3 they are all covered by
the offline distribution and in this
case I might just want to find the best
one among them right I'm not going to
aim for finding the globally optimal
policy in this case but I'm going to aim
to find the best one that is covered by
the offline data
right so let's look at this particular
simple example this is a binary tree
everything is deterministic
deterministic transition
I have rewards zero everywhere on this
tree except the two Leaf nodes I have
rewarded 0.9 on state 10. I have
rewarded one on state 15 0 everywhere
right
so obviously the optimal pass goes along
this direction right the optimal pass
will pick report one
but let's see you know in this case my
offline distribution just covers the
other subtree the the um the left
subtree in this case
so there's literally no hope for me to
identify the optimal paths because I
don't even know what's going to happen
what the transition going to look like
under this red subtree right because I
don't have any sort of evidence in that
part
but maybe in this case what we can hope
for is to actually identify this policy
the policy that is not the globally
optimal it's not globally optimal but
you know it is high quality is
reasonably good
so this is hopefully doable
all right so our goal here is to
basically compete against the best
policy that could be covered by the
offline data so I will talk about I
would Define the coverage mathematically
in in a field sites
okay so another thing we want to achieve
in offline reinforcement especially when
we apply this to large-scale mdps is the
generalization
so in supervised learning as I said you
know we use Rich function proximators to
to achieve generalization in the sense
that we want to make a good predictions
on the examples that we don't see in the
training time
right and uh mathematically what we want
is that our you know pack sample
complexity guarantee only depends on the
statistical complexities of the function
class that I'm using for instance in
this case could be VC Dimension rather
Market complexity or other complexity
measures right and particularly I don't
want my sample complexity bound to
depend on for instance in this case you
know total number of unique cat or dog
image in this world right that's just
not it that's just not impossible
and we want a similar things in offline
reinforcement and general reinforcement
as well because when we apply you know
reinforcement techniques to games like
go we know that the total number of
unique border positions in this case is
larger than total number of atoms in the
universe so there's no hope for us to
sort of enumerate all possible border
positions that are trying to memorize
you know the optimal strategy there
right so we have to be able to
generalize we have to make good
predictions even on those border
positions that we haven't seen during
the training time
so mathematically you know we want to
identify high quality policy with number
of samples scaling
polynomially with respect to the
statistical complexities of some
function tasks that we're going to use
so yeah so in summary of the key
questions are in offline reinforcement
learning can we design an algorithm that
can compete find a policy to compete
against the best policy among those
covered by the offline data and
simultaneously can we achieve this goal
with number of offline samples scaling
polynomically with respect to the
statistical complexities of the function
class that we picked
right so now let's talk about some
specific setting and algorithm
um so different from what Java talked
about in the morning I'm not going to
design function plans to capture sort of
the Q function I'm going to do a model
based approach
so remember we had this unknown
markovian transition so in this case you
know this particular this potentially
could be a stochastic dynamics that is
that models this car for instance right
so this is an unknown so in the model
based approach setting we want to use
function cost to capture the sky so I
may have a family of functions each of
them takes a state action pair as input
and Maps just distribution over the next
state right think about each function
here as sort of a conditional generative
model which takes the state action pair
as input and try to build a distribution
over the state from where we sample the
next state
and we're going to assume that this
function class is rich
such that there exists a function that
can perfectly capture the ground choice
on the model
okay this is a typical realizability
assumption in supervised learning
potentially we can relax it to organize
sticky learning study but I'm not really
going to talk about this today
and in terms of computation let's assume
that we have access to some black box
planning article an oracle that takes Mr
coven transition p as input and a reward
function as input and outputs a policy
that maximizes the reward
so this is a real computation article
so let's look at a very naive approach
um so I think in control this is often
called certainty equivalence what we're
going to do is just take the offline
data and trying to find a model from the
model class from the function class that
fits the data best particularly let's do
maximum located estimation in this case
I'm going to find a model that achieves
you know the maximum likelihood of the
data
once I train this model let's just
pretend that this is the ground Choice
model that's called our black box
planner
to compute the optimal policy right I'm
just trading P hat as if it were the
ground rules transition then I input the
rewarder function to this black box
planner and this guy outputs a policy
and maybe let's just apply this policy
in the real world and see how it goes
so when the offline data is not diverse
enough this approach could generate
terrible policies right so let's look at
this binary tree example again remember
we have rewards zero everywhere except
two nodes right I think node 10 has
reward 0.9 you know the 15 has rewarded
one
and we only have offline data on the
left subtree
so in this case
our model P hat could be arbitrarily run
in the right subtree
particularly maybe you know I would make
completely wrong prediction at the node
3. so in this case maybe my model
believes that you know if you take the
left action and node three you want to
be translated to the right sub tree you
build it at node 7 and if you take an
action the right action view would be
routed to the left subtree loaded at
node 6.
right so we our model actually believes
something that is completely different
from the ground Choice model
and in this case you know if this
planner will pick a policy that looks
like right to left right right because
the planner believes that if you pick
this policy you would achieve rewarded
one in the model P hat
but the reality is that if you execute
this policy in the real world you will
actually just visit a state where you
have rewarded zero you're even gonna
miss
the sub-optimal policy inside the screen
widget
so that's the issue of it's not your
approach now this naive approach could
work really well if you have very
diverse offline data right if the
offline data covers everywhere then this
is a very reasonable model and this is a
model you know people actually sometimes
use in practice too
yeah
so why is it that if you haven't located
about the induction site
tells you
oh maybe just an example basically I was
just saying like you don't know what he
had to do at the region is where you
don't have time all right right I was
just thinking maybe the more natural
things
just assuming everything is
yeah so I would think about this as like
you know you just look at the models
which all have training at all equal to
zero and you should pick one model right
because at that point you don't know
which one is actually that is
foreign
um
so I think when I say the offline
distribution you could think about this
as just maybe that's the distribution of
a state actually it may not mean even
like indicate information there's
verticals okay
okay so let's look at a slightly
different approach which is pretty much
the same method in this one except that
I'm gonna add a little bit constraint in
this case
so the first step is the same I'm going
to train maximal IQ estimator I'm going
to find a model that makes the data as
likely as possible
and once I have this model
I'm going to do this constraint
optimization
right let's forget about the you know
the maximum objective for a second let's
look at the constraint so what this
constraint is saying that I'm only going
to focus on the models which is close to
the maximum likelihood estimator
under the total variation distance
averaged over the training data set
so here Delta is some threshold
right so picture wise I have this this
constrainable which is centered around
the maximum liking the estimator and I'm
only going to look for models inside
this book
right so the intuition behind this is
that I won't know if I set Delta
properly I will know that the ground
Choice model P star lives somewhere
inside this book even though you know I
don't know where that is right
so um this total variation distance
might look a little bit complicated in
from a computation perspective but you
can easily replace this by sort of a
likelihood based constraint right where
you say basically I'm only going to look
at models whose empirical log likelihood
is not falling too below of the input
over log likelihood of the mle
previous example
please
yeah so Delta will be set exactly as the
generalization
because I only want to make sure I only
make sure that P star falls into this
country I want to make sure P star is
applicable Solution on this guy so Delta
is exactly the generalization bound of
Maximum bacteria estimate
okay so once I have this constrained I
will do this Max main optimization so
basically this is that for every policy
Pi I'm only going to compute the
conservative estimation of the policy
value by selecting the the least
favorable model amount
for models in this constraints
once I have this pessimistic or whatever
conservative estimation of the policies
value for every policy I'm just going to
select the policy that has the highest
conservative estimation
that's what this Max main is doing
so now let's talk about the coverage
before we talk about the sample
complexity of this approach
I've been talking about coverage sort of
in high level
now let's define the coverage in this
case so I'm going to use both the
distributions policy induced
distributions and the function class to
Define this coverage
so in the numerator
I have the state action distribution I
induced from a policy Pi that I'm
interested
and in the denominator I have this data
action distribution induced by the
behavior policy
I'm looking at this ratio and inside the
expectation it's just the total
variation distance between a particular
model P Prime and the ground rules P
star so I'm looking at the ratio between
model errors
and then taking Supreme in front of this
guy so this is my density this is my
sort of coverage definition
I will say that a policy pie is covered
if this quantity is bounded below
infinite
so this looks a little bit complicated
let's look at two special cases and
trying to get some intuition of this
quantity
so the first case is that you can always
show that this quantity is upper bounded
by the worst density ratio between these
two distributions
to see and this density ratio based
coverage is a well used is a
well-defined quantity it's a commonly
used quantity in reinforce modeling
and another extreme case is that
this is not going to be realistic but
imagine that somehow you know a lot of
prior knowledge about the system and you
just design a function cost where every
function in the function class looks the
same as the ground Choice One
right so in this case you don't have any
model error so regardless of you know
whether the two distributions is going
to have overlap or not it doesn't really
matter this quantity is going to be
equal to what
right so sometimes this quantity takes
both the distribution and also the
function class power into consideration
okay so this is what the guarantee um uh
we're gonna have from the that previous
uh constraint optimization approach
so particularly given n
ID offline data triples with high
probability we can find a policy Pi hat
that can compete against any policy Pi
stock not necessarily the globally
optimal but any policy as long as it is
covered by the offline data meaning that
this coverage C is bounded below
positive infinite
so this is the robustness that we were
talking about we want to actually
compete against any policy that is
covered by the offline data
and we also have this statistical
complexity of our model class so in this
case for Simplicity I'm just assuming
that my function cost is discrete
contains finite number of functions so
typically in this case the natural
statistical complexity is just the log
of the size of the function class right
and particularly here in this band I
don't have explicit polynomial
dependence on the number of state and
action pairs in this case
everything is hiding inside this
complexity of the function class
this is a supervised venue style
generalization bound we're talking about
right so as you can see here
um
when you do things in model based
perspective all we need is actually just
a coverage and also just realizability
which contradicts to what you know Java
talked about in the morning right we're
in the value function proximation
perspective just being realizability is
actually not enough
this is actually just being
realizability in the queue function is
also actually not enough in the offline
reinforcement inside
okay so let's yeah
I think it becomes there was actually
steps and also the total rewarding this
case the trajectory-wise reward Clinic
so if you zoom like to record what is
bounded between zero one you just get
one match
if you're going into that uh it's this
red dependence and age ultimately
and I would think it's http
yeah so this can if you instantially in
this results to let's see take it this
is definitely not often yeah
and in fact you will get a I think I
mean your apps in this case
if you would expect him to get us
whatever this
I was going to ask the same question it
means so but by the way the algorithm is
like having constraint for each P so
yeah I don't need to think about
hypothesis testing perspective I mean
these are like sequence of things so I
don't know if taking that into account
oh no sorry it's it's not you don't
assume that like the trajectory of
complete observative okay never mind
foreign
[Music]
uh
why is there no dependence on the
Sciences
like the magnitude of the rewards oh
yeah yeah so I think this is
one of them so we just assumed that the
total trajectory like every time you set
the reward is
so RSA is
between zero
then RSA is known they don't learn that
okay
it is
why isn't the regret kind of just amazed
by each
and even if any policy has a story
yeah I think you really have to look at
compounding arrows it's not just like
something everything
this is
so so the thing multiplying it is less
than one
oh oh that's so yeah so this one yes
think about the answers yeah
so let me show you some examples uh
basically this algorithm is generally
such that when you apply this to some
special cases you can actually get very
nice results which actually incorporates
the structures of this special models so
the first model is this uh non-linear
sort of Kernel regular regulator where
we just assume that you have some
deterministic function f star that maps
from State action pair to the next state
corrupted by some gaussian noise so of
course F star is unknown but let's
assume that this guy lives in the sub
reproducing kernel turbo space where the
kernel is defined as the inner product
between these two features right Phi is
the known feature in this case
so um
in this case we can refine that the
ratio based coverage to this relative
condition number style coverage
so here in the numerator you have the
feature covariance Matrix averaged over
the state action distributions induced
by the policy you care about and in the
denominator you have the feature
covariance Matrix corresponding to the
offline distribution
and in some sense we are measuring
coverage in terms of Subspace rather
than density ratio animal thanks
another example that I like I really
like is the low rank mdps so let me just
spend maybe one minute talking about the
low rank mdps so in this low rank mdp
um let's see we have this transition
Matrix which uh is indexed by state
action pair and the next day as Prime so
we have this big Matrix where every
entry in this Matrix is the probability
of transiting to S Prime given essay
right and this could be a very large
Matrix when you're looking at large mdps
what I'm going to assume here is that
this Matrix has rank D where D is
significantly smaller than the number of
states and action pairs
so this factorization looks like that
and put it in a different way you can
just assume you have mu star in a five
star two mappings
such that for every state action next
State triple you can write the
probability of transiting to S Prime at
essay as the inner productivity of these
two vectors right and the dimension of
these two vectors are D which is the
rank of The Matrix
so in low rank mdp neither mu star No 5
star is no right so for those of you who
heard about linear mdp this is really
different in the sense that five star
here is unknown where linear NDP assumes
low rankness and also 5 Star B in though
right which will really allow you to do
sort of use linear regression techniques
to solve an aerial problem here you just
can't really use it in your regression
technique right because you don't know
if I stock
right
um I'm going to set up two function
classes in this case because neither
muse.no if I start no so I'm just going
to assume I have two function classes
gamma Phi and both the capture mu
starting five star respectively
so this is the realizability assumption
and in this case
in coverage condition
can be reduced to again the relative
condition number but in this case the
relative condition number will be
defined using the ground rules feature
five star which is unknown
great
and then in terms of the performance Gap
we will get a sub-optimality gap that
looks like that
um so we will have log of the size of
two function classes in this case
because we have two you know we started
with two function class and we have this
D which is the rank of The Matrix
so here if you record the algorithm the
first step is running mle so in that
step we are really trying to solve a
nonlinear function so if a non-linear
function approximation like a non-convex
optimization problem
um you say the the coffee
but if it's not right we know it's just
a no-dimensional
like half might stick
like we it's it's a lower dimensional
Subspace so a linear Subspace
two D dimensional subspaces
so I'm trying to figure out how to get
the cardinality for these
two linear subspaces so if you go to the
next
so you have the the cardinality of of
those two pumps yeah
no so here I'm just still assuming these
two function classes at District
the number of sub States is considered
spinal
yeah I'm just looking at a finite
function classes and I'm willing to
paint a lot of assets
of course in worst case these probably
will scale with respect the number of
states right but I'm just assuming that
I have good enough advice
oh yeah
so like all we're doing here is MLD and
all we need is the standard supervised
version style generation
right I'm
several other interesting models like
the mixture ndps and also Factor the
mdbs
so now let me briefly talk about
imitation only so this is a setting
where you don't have real water function
anymore right so this is setting where
you know specifying the reorder function
that tried to quantify the long-term
behavior is really hard
think about those robotics problems
right writing on the reward function is
not easy but you potentially can ask
some human expert to provide
demonstration
so this is the setting that we're going
to look at you can also call this
inverse reverse planning if you want
so this is a typical imitation learning
setting you often start with an expert
demonstration
and you do data collection and you train
a policy using that expert demonstration
and you deploy this policy right and
very famous algorithm is called Behavior
cloning and people actually use that you
know to train self-driving cars back in
1989
so CMU did that
1989 they trained a self-driving car
trunk using this Behavior colony and
they actually drove the car from you
know Pittsburgh to West Coast
it was a new works paper in 1989.
and the policy is a neural network
okay of course you know you're gonna
have covarian shift in imitation
learning as well right so this was the
example that we saw you're going to have
running into situations like that but
imagine this case I have a bunch of you
know imperfect but offline
demonstrations from maybe non-expert
drivers right I could have you know
different people driving the car around
this track but they are not racing
experts
but maybe I can use these data sets to
learn how to actually recover from
mistakes
and this is what we're going to do so
the setting is that we have lots of
offline data but we only have very few
high quality demonstrations so in this
robotics control case you know maybe I
have a lot of offline data of this robot
doing very similar tasks these are cheap
you know I log them
but for today's task I may gonna ask
some experienced experts coming into my
lab and provide a few demonstrations you
know experience the expert is expensive
they probably have a lot of other things
they want to do so train this high
quality demonstrations is not that cheap
so can we combine these two sources
together to learn a good policy to
control this robot
and again I don't have rewarder function
right it's not very easy to write down
the reward function to control this
robot
okay so the framework looks like that I
have two sources of data the offline
data might not be perfect I have expert
demonstrations perfect but I only have
very few of them right and I want a
design approach that takes these two
sorts of data set into import and I'll
call the policy that potentially can
work well when I deploy them in the real
world
so let's zoom into this box
um so inside this box I have two
procedures the first procedure is still
the model Based training so in this case
I'm gonna use the offline data to train
a model together with some sort of
uncertainty qualification so this P hat
is the estimated model and sigma is some
uncertainty quantification which
basically says that for every state
action pair the deviation between the
learner model and the ground rules is
upper bounded by the sigma
so in this for if if you use gaussian
process in this case Sigma probably is
you know the epistemic uncertainty right
so we're gonna assume we have these two
pieces of inflammation from the model
training part and once we have that
we're going to start using the expert
demonstrations and we're trying to do
some sort of inverse reinforcement
learning and the way we're going to do
this is to do this may Max procedure
right so this looks a little bit
complicated but let's pass each term one
by one so here F think about them as a
Distributors right and in inverse audio
literature people also call them cost
functions
so the discriminator is trying to
distinguish the distribution of our
policy and the distribution of the
expert pause so this is literally some
sort of modification of integral
probability metric between two
distributions right
and
here the expectation the first
expectation is inside the learner model
P hat remember I don't have online
access right or I can trust is the model
that I trained
but my model could be terribly round on
the places where I don't have too much
data so what we're going to do is add a
little bit of penalty inside this
discriminator function
so if you think about discriminator f as
sort of cost that you're learning along
the way when you're solving this min max
procedure then this Sigma just looks
like a penalty I'm basically telling the
learner that you should not go to those
regions where this penalty is large
right because these regions
corresponding to the part of the state
space where you don't have too much
offline data you should focus yourself
under the region where you have data and
try just to do your best to mimic the
experts there
that's sort of the intuition and picture
wise uh let's see I have this 2D space
and this green region contains the
offline data so outside of this green
region I have high uncertainty I can't
really trust the model and at all so I
shouldn't really trying to imitate the
expert for instance so inside the screen
region this this is a good region I can
trust my model so in the ideal case if
my expert distribution falls into this
region then I can really use this
offline data to do better than just a
simple behavioral cloning algorithm
because I can actually trust the model
and use the model to figure out how to
correct my mistake whenever I deviate
from the expert demonstrations right I
can pull myself back to the expert
demonstration
using this model but in the worst case
you know when the expert distribution is
outside of this offline data there's a
literally not that much we can do except
just running very traditional you know
Behavior clothing algorithm disk
so let's look at how this works so we
apply this approach to the to sort of
control the simulated human eye robot to
work as fast as possible
so we have expert performance which is a
really good expert can actually make the
robot run as fast as possible
and we collected a very few
demonstrations maybe just one or two
trajectories
and in this case if you just run
Behavior cloning you know the very
classic imitation of the algorithm on
these very few demonstrations you get a
pretty bad policy and from this video
perspective it's just a policy that
doesn't even know how to make the low
bar stand
right and another case is that after we
collected a bunch of offline data let's
just treat the offline data as if we're
in the ground like a very high quality
expert data let's just combine the two
sorts of data together and train
Behavior columns in this case so let's
do a little bit better
so from this video point it learns sort
of stand and take one step and then
Force down
but when you combine these two sources
together using the approach that we were
describing you can actually learn a
policy then make the robot moving
forward as fast as possible this weird
behavior is due to the expert policy the
expert policy is only optimized to move
the robot forward in time it's not
penalizing these weird behaviors okay
okay so let me summarize what I talked
about
um so in this talk I was really
emphasizing two sort of properties for
offline reinforcement learning the first
one is generalization the second one is
robustness in terms of generalization as
I was saying we want to sort of do it
offline RL as if we were doing
supervised learning in the sense that we
learned with Rich function approximation
and we want to generalize using Rich
function approximation and then the
robustness is that when we have
insufficient coverage from the offline
data we should hope that our approach
can learn to compete against the best
policy that could be covered by the
offline data
so that's it I'm happy to take any
questions thank you
[Applause]
can you talk a little bit about the
difficulty uh optimizing for the low
rank mdp in the constrained optimization
problem yeah so for this framework I
don't even know how to really optimize
the table NDP unless I factorize my
constraints to be this like rectangular
basic constraint like I factorize the
total variation distance average over
the training data to make each sales
then I can run like extended
um
yeah so this is not really a
computationally efficient algorithm
I think it's interesting to see that
what we can do uh computation
the second question so how did you get
the video
right now
yeah so there's a Max over F what we do
is solving this Max min max Problem by
Computing best response over f so the F
in this case is just linear functions on
some predefined curve so this ipf IPM in
this case is just MLB so you do have
closed phone solution
containing half
and then you do policy gradient under
the policy part
and we ran some natural policy to
minimize that so you do a small update
on Pi but you compute best response for
the dish
and the model is trained by adoption
process so you have this uh actually the
model is trained by example of neurodex
where the uncertainty quantification is
the distribution over the neural
um you said you were going to talk about
lower bounds but I'm like Curious how
hard this problem is like what what is
known for the lower down perspective
also the lower bounding offline area is
for model 3 side so imagine you asking
the question that I want to do policy
evaluation
and I had some offline data that
actually covers the entire State space
meaning that the density ratio between
the policy you want to evaluate and the
ground rules so the offline distribution
is about it
and you just assume real activity in the
sense that your function class contains
the coupon you will estimate you still
can't do it you need
in this case is not enough
foreign
and your offline data actually has
coverage in terms of the eigen values of
the covariance Matrix this is your line
but I'm trying to say here is that
realizability model based cases
but of course you know assuming
realizability model cost is stronger
than a zero that's really in the Q
function class
specifically
mostly at the expertise
yeah so yeah you can think about this
way but like in this framework or in
general invitation and you really have
to sort of think about expert as the
global optimal policy so your goal is
also different right you just want to do
it as good as the expert your lawyers do
not complete optimal Parts I guess my
question was like oops is that important
in selecting an expert that will be
close to the one that was maximizing the
previous things that we saw about the
covenants then
like are you assuming Express that's
been completely acceptable
to be someone
it's diverse as diverse as possible so
the behavior of how it could be titled
right but the Oxford policy there are
you sort of hoping that it's actually
doing the correct thing like because
you're trying to match the distribution
of that guy so you wanted that
distribution actually she could expect
it a bit more
so the the role of the offline Behavior
policy is to help you do some
exploration
uh
the first step we are within you are
doing the maths like a couple of days is
that a crucial or any kind of estimation
method yeah yeah you can do those main
marks approaches so when I do the
maximum IQ destination I'm really just
using the total variation distance
generalization bound I that you don't
have to if you have a discriminator
that's you can do many marks right it's
trying to train a model such as some
sort of you know Divergence like IPM
divergences
and but you needed to make sure somehow
your discriminary class is Rich enough
to capture potential value functions
that you could run into the future
right because you're really going to
evaluate your model together with
somebody function
I'm going to stick to another business
plan
for helping them
Elizabeth
foreign